car welcome to avenger cup welcome to
avengers con
mom come pick me up i don't like it here
oh my gosh it's friday and welcome back
to the break room
love to see your little roomies your
little breakers you're looking great out
there uh it's friday and you know what
happens on friday in the break room we
act insane that's right we've lost our
minds at the end of the week and we're
glad you're here to join us uh we've got
a great panel lined up today i'm of
course tony stank uh and i'm so happy
with you
so many of my friends uh on the far side
of the table uh she is being reasonable
it's whitney van
lenningham
this is me being reasonable
and we didn't even tell her to dress up
today this is how she came to work today
scarlet wit [ __ ] what's that oh
yeah there should be no swear jars on
fridays or when i'm on the show yeah i
think that both of those things we could
work that out right uh and sitting next
to whitney of course we have jessica
hook smash
i go by she [ __ ]
oh my gosh uh and sitting next to me
here uh he's usually tiny but today he's
pretty
large you got a little ant-man action oh
my gosh stay out of my pee hole please
oh [ __ ] i was a late edition uh which is
why i stole my costume from the set you
may recognize this helmet from the set
that's right um
i go by [ __ ] man oh my god
ugh why you should have this we have the
uh the thumbnail on hand of like ant-man
takes giant dumps that everyone loves so
much that everyone thinks is the best
thumbnail a classic big question a show
that no longer exists on this channel
you can look it up on the channel after
the break room does uh does ant-man take
massive dumps he does it's a really good
thumbnail uh
it's a great thumbnail uh yes it is
friday we're going crazy uh we don't
have the swear jar today despite what
the bottom of the screen says we're
short staffed again tommy uh had a bowel
movement that went long i think and zach
another button and another train and
another yeah if you were here yesterday
you know that both zac and tommy love to
fight public transportation and they're
at it again uh but we we love our super
chatters out there we already had some
coming into the show uh uh uh paul
ballard i believe saying i'm drinking
white claws on the couch and binging
stranger things
literally
all
weekend
be drinking on the break room i don't
know i don't know
i've already been doing it oh yeah
mine's pretty yeah but we do have we
don't have to swear dry today but we do
have a chat redemption fever uh uh
feature today we do we do have a chat
redemption feature you guys
today's friday like everyone has already
stated we're a little tipsy we're going
to get getting tipsier by the moment but
if you get to 100 if we get to 100 you
get to choose which one of us finishes
our drink one of us will finish our
drink and you're like jessica that's
okay but what about 200 if you get to
200 someone's gonna get popped in the
face with one of these
it's not the face don't do that put it
in the face pizza papa papa paid um
not only will another person finish
their drink we will also pop another one
in someone's face and we get to break
open this secret pinata we don't know
what's inside of it i don't we have no
idea
there could be live spiders inside of
that thing we don't even know mr krabs
is getting his deadpool mask at home if
you're at home and you want to dress up
for avenger con i mean look at this look
at this beautiful sign the only reason i
came to work today i'm not joking the
only reason was because they told me i
could get drunk and wear a halloween
costume i was like hell yeah yeah they
also we also in great miss marvel
avenger con fashion
we each will allow you guys to vote in
the chat who had the best costume and
whoever has the best costume has awarded
a trophy oh a real troll yes yes um what
would you say the emoji for tony stank
is i think tony stank's emoji there's a
stinky sign isn't there
like a stinky emoji we got a little
stinky
i don't know if there's anything like
that what reasons tony stark when did
you want to do like how about a
tombstone how about a tombstone for tony
put a tombstone for tony what would you
say for ant-man i want that little i
want the
although
little
pinch
this oh the little pinch emoji for
ant-man
um i'm gonna just say the green dot for
she-hulk because it's easy
easy i'm gonna go with the flaming heart
oh the flaming heart what is her heart
if not always on fire where are you oh
my god
she's depressed she's exactly like me
let's go let's go so vote in the chat
with the tombstone for tony stank the
pinch emoji for aunt
[ __ ] amp whatever you call
and the flaming heart for scarlet wit
oh look at all those tombstones oh
there's a lot of tubes already going in
oh thank god oh my god they aren't they
didn't bother by the way you guys i
laughed harder than i think i have in an
entire week when i saw brandon come out
with them
and i do want to put out the lovely uh
avengers calm mural we have in honor of
miss marvel so cool jessica worked on
this mural uh
one of our production assistants uh sam
worked on this mural we didn't know she
had this thing i will say that 85
96 of this is sam's doing uh all the
ones that look ugly i did and she had to
adjust to it for instance this captain
america shield where i didn't really do
it right sam drew captain america hold
it i love how hunched over he is he's
like i don't know yeah what is this
where are you gonna light up when you
first told me sam helped work on it i
was like the dog
names like oh wait [ __ ] there's also a
person not as talented not as talented
the dog bites the dogs
nowhere near getting a lot of a lot of
flavor i said green dot i'm getting a
lot of green
we're getting a lot of tombstones a lot
of flaming hearts oh i like that
everyone decided that you deserve a
heart instead of a hole
yeah that's nice that words
i also saw two comments that said
jessica and green face look here
look here you guys it wouldn't have been
green face if my entire body was paid in
green but someone rushed me
me
we were already late let's get into the
headlines oh wait did we already break
the hundred did we already break the
whole thing we just got
yeah well someone else do a drink
because i gotta i gotta read the
headlines look i'll check my drink
chug your drink while i read the
headlines
i'm gonna finish my drink for you
what's the name i uh
and gravity grav vote
for putting us over the top
thank you and also thank you john attend
we had a we had several of them reed
coles bruce de la cruz and mr krabs
some super chats today all right let's
get into some of these headlines uh big
news today marvel will be skipping this
year's comic con with no panels or major
announcements planned uh disney is
shifting all of its marvel stuff to
focus on its annual d23 convention oh my
god big win for the disney adults i know
i'm kind of bad
d23 gets sold out so quickly just by the
disney fans
we are probably gonna have some folks
from new rock stars i love d23 never
mind you guys everybody loves that's
right and they've got they're they're
having their disney plus day the day
before disney yeah d23 starts um they
just put out like a a d23 magazine with
a lot of interesting news about floor 11
thunder though
is amazing
i will pretend to be a disney adult if
you let me and jessica go i am
a pixar tattoo
uh
yeah this is kind of interesting right
because like uh warner brothers has its
own uh fan day you know it does it's
it's breakdown uh
i didn't know warner bros i know dc fans
don't know dc fans
right they kind of took their stuff out
now disney's kind of taking their stuff
out which is kind of fun i love the idea
of comic con getting a little back a bit
more back to just like the comics and
stuff like that uh you know i love the
floor i don't always go to all the
panels i love the like action on the
floor that is the that's the point of
going to conventions is spending your
money right the the art there it's just
next yeah you know the cosplay and stuff
it does remind me of like what's
happening with e3 where all the video
game companies started they're like
we'll do our own day thank you very much
we'd like to have our own little
convention going on so also the number
one thing that i learned like the first
time i went to comic con was that
nerds party harder than anyone i've ever
seen what am i doing never seen dude i
know i know
like us though you know it's all of them
it's all of us collectively i had no
idea yeah when you get a nerd out of the
house you know they cut them they go
they do cut loose
thank you guys for all the green emojis
in the chat
uh another headline following the
conclusion of his uh steve rogers
character in avengers which one is steve
rogers i forget um uh chris evans
chris evans says a return would be quote
a tall order this is his whole quote
that he gave uh
it's so precious to me it would have to
be perfect it would just be scary to
rattle something that is again so
so dear to me that role means so much to
me so to revisit it
it would be a tall order yeah so he was
doing press for for light year and this
comes off the heels of a report from
earlier last year that said that he was
going to return right to play steve
rogers again in a future marvel
something or other i remember he did he
did one of those variety like actors on
actors things with
maybe it was scarlett johansson maybe it
was christian stuart i don't remember um
and he basically said like you know the
way we wrapped up cap's story
something really important or good or
you know
some some you you only have to return
for something really meaningful right
like what's he gonna
[Music]
i'm not watching listen we have old
country for old men already
no country foreign
i kept looking at i got zoned in on the
chat i got zoned in on this loving all
those green emojis out there thank you
mr krabs by the way clint to you as well
yeah thank to you
also i like the i just love the idea
that this is an avengers con and new
rock stars is doing the panel for it
right
we're we're finishing the panel you guys
act like you just waited in line for 20
hours also where's eric voss in the chat
so it feels real
yeah
where is he um yeah i think he's right
though taking an eternal pause i hope we
don't need
we don't need a back right away uh we
certainly don't even cat-back but marvel
you know the mcu is not answering where
he is they're not saying he's dead dead
they're not saying he's on the moon i'm
not weird they're leaving it open you
got to think
just is like i don't want to answer this
question that's their uh break glass in
case of emergency right there could be a
cap out there somewhere i don't know no
no no a paper towel i don't know a paper
towel
it's a single one
i think i'm on whitney's side where i'm
like i i also how are you not going to
ask him a captain america question at
the premiere of of course like right
like right
yeah but i feel the same way about tony
stark when there was kind of like the
rumors you know we'd see tom cruise as
tony stark but even that we would see
another robert downey jr as tony stark
in multiverse of madness
the longer they stay away the better the
better and that return will be happening
we had that we had toby and andrew come
back and what was it was like at least
five years from the last andrew movie or
at least i don't know almost 15 years or
something like that and it was so
rewarding yeah i would love to see
robert downey jr pop up in an mcu movie
and way too many years yeah way down the
line um another headline a credit
listing as quote makeup artist to miss
steinfeld still unwed was spotted in the
credits for miss marvel still unwed uh
it could be a mistake but it's certainly
something very interesting do we think
we could see kay bishop show up uh in
the miss marvel series is that the cameo
that i want to i want it they're doing
like a young avengers well okay so if
you had to choose this is why i say i
want it if you had to choose between the
young avengers and only one could appear
which one would it be right
uh
yeah i mean because i would wanted to be
kate bishop okay bishop is fun she's
sweet i'll take billy and tommy if they
sing the ice cream song no get out of
here no kick them out if they say no if
they don't i'll cry oh good
keep it away from me keep it away from
me give it away for me this is really
interesting right um episode credits on
television shows are per episode they're
not per series and we obviously didn't
and this was in the first episode this
is the first episode i think we have a
graphic of it i don't know if it was
already up uh okay yeah so here we go uh
makeup artist mrs steinfeld um there's
purple one else on the cast james stein
film
that's the thing is it's a common
question it's not it's not a bad last
name but it's not the same star they
don't credit everything right no one no
one is a personal makeup no one gets
special makeup unless it's in your
contract and you have your person and so
haley steinfeld seems like the person i
mean it could be right they had they had
the file of these are the credits filed
for marvel shows and someone didn't edit
it right when they were just it's copy
i just will not rest until the name on
those credits says makeup assistant to
mrs attainment and it's she's married to
empty
would be adorable
mt we know you're watching take mr
tayman that's your name
whitney i'm curious to hear from you um
where where would you like if if haley
steinfeld does do uh a cameo in miss
marvel where would you like her to show
up how would you like her to be
introduced
oh man i just want to watch her kill a
guy you just want to just kill a guy
totally unrelated supply she just we
just cut away and she starts shooting
people in the face
yeah no i love it kill again
she will she will kill again go
um mr krabs said clink i'm going to
clink because you know where i'm going
to clean why are you going to why you
guys know how i'm going to clean it
let's clank grill's quickly let's get
out of the cheers for cheers cheers
right now tomatoes
you know what i have to climb under the
table real quick to get myself another
beer
chaos is adorable this is absolutely
adorable we're not drinking beer you're
drinking
fruit juice don't don't trip you'll get
a boo boo because you're gonna play my
graphic for two play it again
i'm not even on screen for a play for
you i
know me from the scene
why do you hate me is it because i said
play it for three go ahead he was
already ready for that one he wasn't
people
sometimes i really wasn't ready for that
one
the chat is like they're not really
drinking but today i feel like it's
pretty you're on twitter
you guys i know that this is a hot topic
it's been trending on twitter training
everywhere though the thunderbolts movie
is coming and i already got a director
like a director he's got a writer he's
got a writer
doesn't even have a director watch us
get a trailer for this before black
panther so
before you read her name can i correct
you real quick can we call her florence
pug because that's what i like to call
her joseph lauren's bike
the thunderbolts movie looks to be a go
and the rap is reporting that florence
pugs yelena belova
my return to star which is insane we
thought it would be fun to assemble our
own dream team to the thunderbolts you
guys
this is uh this news that she's going to
return to start that's a still pretty
rumory we think or i don't know
you know the the person from the rap
reporting we were talking about this a
lot in the office right yeah we call
this a rumor do we call this news
um
sort of right there in in between it
makes a lot of sense for her to be or a
ruse a ruse it makes a lot of sense for
her to be in this movie you know we
think
we we know a rough grouping of people
who will be in this movie right we've
got val
we have john walker u.s agent we have
elena bulova um
she doesn't have a name she's going down
below she's just you laying there we'll
call it
okay okay so are where are we going
what's up we're going to go here's what
i want us to do and i'm stealing this i
know it is
whoa
with those three people in mind
let's all come up with our own group of
thunderbolts uh and not including those
people because those people feel like
guarantees right so let's all write down
five names
five five humans
or non-humans um
for this new thunderbolts lineup uh you
have a better marker you want a better
there's more you guys in the chat go
ahead and tell us who you would like who
would you like to see on in the
thunderbolts what is going on today
what is going on around this tournament
in the chat to nick p who sent us a very
kind message sergio gutierrez who said
love the break room guys um
and everyone in the chat today we
appreciate you for being with us on a
friday uh can i finish what i was gonna
say please
i was vamping
five five years hey look here listen
look at camera four sometimes you get
cut off and sometimes you gotta finish
what you're saying later but in the chat
please let us know what you're going for
let me know what you're going for
because i might actually take that idea
and remember that if you do tip and if
you do or not tip if you do do a super
chat or any of that i'll check another
drink
just one super chat you're going to
chuck another drink just one super chat
of mine you guys get
a classic one from sex in the city we're
about 30 doubloons off from our 200 mark
where the poppers get popping so you
guys get to choose who gets to pop
please choose me
please choose me
please choose me
do you want to go uh i can go i've got
so we're supposed to have five i got one
more to fill in but here's here's where
i'll start off okay i want to see my boy
abomination okay i love it i think
they're trying to make them nice i want
to keep them bad all right let them let
them do the good on the thunderbolts
they're good that's the heavy quotes uh
uh but he'll still be killing people you
know i mean he's still gonna get away
with a little death every now and then
bucky wants to see my boy bucky turn
back to a little more of a meaner side
they've made them too
nice
they've made them too kind i want them
to be assassinating people again uh zemo
break them out of jail put them on the
thunderbolts let's go uh
taskmaster i don't want to hear it in
the chat okay
let's get taskmaster master on there all
right she's angry she wants some revenge
let's let her do her thing i do and this
would be a great kind of redemptive
moment for that character i think so too
you know that the mcu is really good
about taking characters they maybe
whiffed on the first time and bringing
them back and giving i'm not gonna call
it a whiff i'm not gonna call it away
but i think we wanted a little more from
taskmaster we wanted her to talk more
that's for sure uh let's get her back in
i love that skull mask i love it uh and
then my last one i mean you gotta have
them usage agent john walker he's got to
be he said not to choose that one oh
don't choose that one he said don't
choose the three obviously
johnny manning oh okay
uh wow
yeah we'll keep it under suspense
i haven't written my fifth down because
oh i'll go
no it's a big reveal
uh here we go my number one choice uh
similar to you zuma's got comments we
need a little bit more dancing from zemo
he's got to come back um he's just such
an agent of chaos right uh number two
uh previous thunderbolts contributor in
the comics this are going to be our
first introduction to deadpool oh in the
mcu okay who who who toes the line
between morally gray better than
deadpool he would be good i mean a lot
he definitely killed he definitely
killed
um
i got number three
an underrepresented character in the mcu
we know him from hawkeye swordsman uh i
think this is just such a funny
character sort's been
walking around with his sword out um all
the time i want to see more of that uh i
think it's like a really funny fight
style that we don't get a lot of in the
mcu and okay for me
this would be jack duquesne
absolutely
just like i love the different fight
styles that we get in the mcu we we had
strong chi which had like such a breath
of fresh air in terms of the fight
choreography right
bring swordsman back um and then to that
point
uh he and elena will recruit kate bishop
to be sort of rounding out my foursome
for
uh we we heard we wanted it we all heard
it we heard okay we heard we wanted uh
more arrows in the faces i agree we want
more arrows from the faces number five
for me
i want a scroll
nick fury
talos okay not talos i think like i
think someone
kind of on the morally gray end of the
spectrum should steal nick fury's
identity we had a nick fury val
relationship in the comics a little bit
i want i want a little bit more of that
in this thunderbolts uh movie uh i am
before you go i am seeing great ones in
the chat i'm writing them down so we'll
go through them you stole them i stole
it no no i'm not stealing them from the
chat i'm just i'm writing them down but
you can steal them i'm stealing them
from the chat
i'm saying they're in the chat also i
think we actually broke again we did
break we break we brought we broke oh we
broke by a big market thank you so much
phil meadows asking us to pop the
confetti and those bottles uh jamil hall
saying happy friday from the east coast
take a drink with me and cheers okay how
about you beanie saying happy friday uh
i a patron someone should shock in a
beer oh my gosh they're trying to kill
you we were driving blue gorilla wants
you to blow them a kiss
that costs a lot of money oh like they
pay for a lot of money who who do you
guys want to chug their beer but i've
already assigned whitney to pop the
confetti first you want to do it this
episode is off the rails and i love it
nine times you want do it on my fifth
one do it on my fifth one so it also has
something like this
so
yeah so i'm being something um i'm also
using task master i'm using taskmaster
we all love taskmaster in the comics
bring them back redeem them from what
they what we saw on black widow um you
guys heard me here before that i was
like
master i'm very upset bring them back
redeem them um i said wilson fisk
i think it's fun to put villains on
teams with people and especially when
the villain does villainy things so i
think there's a lot of good team players
yeah it's not literally killmonger in
the what if episode i was like i'll do
the same thing
[Laughter]
he's like
[Laughter]
um i also said on a non-funnier note i
put the punisher because realistically
yes of course put the punisher on there
and for my fifth
ready go wide shot wide shot white
don't point it at me yeah i know i don't
want it let's try this one and then i'm
and for number five this is live so we
can't edit it is
please
about my nation adorable because you
need a whole okay i really just thought
you were gonna say
obama hey your husband and marvel
comments and michelle and michelle
it was very hard to see who in the chat
you guys wanted to finish their drink
which means i think that the three of us
are all finishing our drinks
he's got a drink he's he's nursing happy
friday someone's got to drive you kids
home yeah someone literally is a great
driver
skaters
okay
yeah i didn't know we were all being
serious well i want to hear them
better good she said lamar's dead body i
think you're okay i was serious about it
though okay
tim curry is nine years old
okay curious frankenfurter oh tim curry
is texas oh tim curry from clue and
number one tim curry from muppet
treasure island oh that's tim curry
thunderbolts she wrote it down here she
wrote it down folks she wrote it down
i didn't even know we were really picky
you know we put thumbnails on this
channel and people click on videos and
thank you guys it's serious discussion
the funny thing is this is clickbait
it's like you want to learn and then we
i wanna i wanna hear your fifth option
okay and then i'm throwing a curveball
okay my fifth option and i did steal
this from czech chat throughout some
good ones like mordo punisher charles
xavier
uh i saw this in chat and i really like
it so i'm gonna take it sorry whoever
said this i want to see the bullseye
from the daredevil series because they
kind of left him still alive right he
gets injured and then he gets the
machinery put in bring him back put him
on the thunderbolts he'd be a lot of fun
that's great i love a little bullseye
i'm very disappointed and surprised you
didn't put my name on that list
jessica clements yeah i would like to
see
no actually sorry confused hulk [ __ ]
here's the curveball i want to introduce
you okay what is it what is it i'm so
sorry to tell you guys this what val is
dead
who is they paid a lot for her
you know the good guys got to her um
who is your leader who the thunderbolts
always have a leader who is your
thunderbolts leader now that vowels out
of the picture out of the five that we
have out of the five you have oh none of
these aren't there well i would bring in
i would bring in norman osborn to be the
leader he's the best leader but where
he's out of his mind he's cheating he's
out of his mind
um
mine has got to be the smartest person
on this list it's nemo
he's a bad leader he's an agent of chaos
yeah i want i want zemo pulling the
strings a little bit more i like that i
like that
i think mine would have to be
i know i think it has to be wilson fisk
right it's between wilson fisker and
punisher but wilson fist doesn't work
under anyone that's the thing is like
even if i did assign it to the punisher
wilson fisk would be like no that's not
how we work and it'll smash them into
the ground
i'm most excited i know what it has to
be i would like to say that tim curry
from up at treasure island yes
i would like to say that oh no but who's
actually in charge in that situation is
realistically miss piggy that's true
so miss piggy is my vow
because piggy gets to join the
thunderbolts just because there's a
vacancy you know the mcu the muppet
cinematic universe of course
baby it's pride month paintamenti says
uh happy friday y'all happy friday to
you too do we think roxanne could make
an appearance in the thunderbolts always
please always it's sitting out there
waiting for us we saw in the first iron
man uh we saw a sign for it and then we
see it again in loki right in the future
roxanne's out there somewhere where are
they how are we on oh we just did our
chugging of drinks i was about to ask
how are we on the super chat do we have
to pop another confetti
yeah we do because holy [ __ ] oh my god
bar lost 69 oh no i'm sorry bartles 69
thank you so much for your super chat
saying jessica brain stew just got to
the party you guys look amazing thank
you so much for your two hundred dollars
superman i can't jump that much it's
right it's friday i get to pop this i
think this show is off the rails we're
gonna get the stock messages from the
people upstairs i think i think we
forgot to mention too that uh this mac
and cheese needs to be chugged at some
point
but we're cooking it first we're not
eating the noodles wrong no we gotta
snort just the powder
all right okay okay this family show
while we finish our drinks and pop
everything brandon do you want to go
through some of the chat uh the the
great chat keep it a wide screen because
i'm gonna pop this confetti and i'm
gonna rip apart this with my strong
she-hulk muscles oh wow do you want
which one you want me to do first
you're the captain i think we gotta
escalate right yeah you gotta do the pop
and then break it okay okay do the prop
happy friday happy friday as i walk
through the valley of the shadow of
death i really take a look at my life in
real life
i'm a lawyer i had babies they had
babies
[Applause]
little babies okay
it was a mother it was a mother and i
ripped her apart
like i do most mothers oh my gosh
[Laughter]
happy bride month okay this episode has
gone off the rails it's friday oh it's
friday i'm sorry that you invited me
uh should we get to our break room
breakdown i think we should and we'll be
we'll be finishing our drinks as i do
the break room breakdown you guys
we're talking about eric foster's miss
marvel breakdown today oh oh i forgot
that i have a graphic that's how gone i
am
um you guys we're going to be talking
about eric vos's breakdown of ms marvel
today let's go ahead and take a look
really quick hell yeah
you guys it's friday i don't think this
is what we were supposed to be talking
about next oh i think this is in here
from yesterday let's let's
let's move on to this oh wait you guys
when i said we were short stuffed i
really wanted to apologize
we are having a hard time
here on the break room today and what
you said let's move on to our
breakthrough breakdown i had an internal
panel i saw it on there i got excited uh
listen listen you guys i didn't i should
have corrected myself because i was
about to be like i haven't seen the
video yet
you didn't send me the breakdown okay
okay okay here's the thing here's the
thing uh you always say that this show
isn't live well it's live clearly
and what makes this show great
this is scripting
it's barely scripted
what makes this show so great is the
energy we bring to this show and how do
we get that energy we get it through g
fuel we get it through g fuel we get it
through g i can't believe i opened that
one folks you've all heard of g fuel
yesterday john opened this limited
edition canister that was worth five
thousand dollars he opened it
it's based on carnage okay it's the red
ooze uh eliminated dish it's destroyed
it's worthless no longer mitten box hey
maybe you don't like powders you know
what you know what g-fuel is it's an
energy drink it's sugar-free it's made
from natural ingredients it's used by
athletes it's used by esports athletes
they're the same thing i don't know why
i categorize categorize them like that
it's used by moms it's used by dads it
probably shouldn't be used by children
but it's delicious to drink it comes in
so many lovely flavors uh and if you're
like hey i hate powders i hate mixing
powder together i hate the 1993 movie
powder it was awful uh uh even though i
like everything else what's that with
powder huh it's a bad movie go watch it
again it's problematic jeff goldblum is
questionable in that film what if you
don't like mixing powders you can buy a
pre-mixed g-fuel that comes in a can
wouldn't that be lovely to have a
pre-mixer you're feeling like i love
that those are the best ones those are
my favorites jessica loves these you
have to keep away from her because she's
dangerous you saw what she did to this
pregnant unicorn she destroyed it uh and
maybe you're like hey
i like the taste of g fuel but i can't
have all this caffeine they have a
caffeine free version it's called g-fuel
hydration this one's gotten moist
critical on it isn't that adorable uh
this doesn't have any caffeine but it
makes you feel a little more hydrated
makes you feel like pedialyte it's kind
of like pediatrics i mean i'm hungover
which is for children and drinking
adults which most of us are yeah sorry
um if you want to try some g fuel for
yourself or you you love the taste of g
full and you need to re-up your supply
head on over to our affiliate link g
fuel dot l y slash new rockstars again
that's g fuel dot l y slash new
rockstars for 10 off your g fuel order
that's a delicious discount and we get a
little taste of that money too so if you
like the channel if you like what we're
doing here if you like how awful we're
behaving live on the internet uh please
support us and check out that affiliate
link which you can also find in the
description below we also want to shout
out our merch partners at epic hero
merch uh epic hero shop they've got a
new we've got a new latest obsession
shirt based on the miss marvel show
which we all love so dearly that's why
we're holding avengers con today uh this
shirt is called cosmic daydream uh and
it features the artwork similar to what
you see on miss marvel it's a beautiful
shirt it looks lovely there uh and we
still for a little bit of time also have
our uh latest obsession shirt based on
obi-wan kenobi called empire's most
wanted both of these shirts are limited
edition once they're gone they're gone
forever you can't slip into uh the
astral plane to pick yourself out a new
one they're gone you can't get them
anymore okay uh and when you purchase
these latest obsession shirts you unlock
the opportunity to get a custom shout
out on one of our after shows whether
it's wikileaks or star wars after show
or inside marvel or miss marvel after
show
those custom shout outs will appear on
the show and may even be read out by the
host of the show uh eric voss and mr
taymout himself or tommy bechdel if
you're on uh the wikileaks show and
don't forget to check out our tumblr we
know you freaks out there like tumblr
and jessica is running our tumblr right
now okay uh don't don't start it off
that way
i'm not doing freaky things on this
we're not doing freaky things but freaks
love tumblr and normal people love
tumblr moms love tumblr dad loves tumblr
the kids love tumblr check out our
official new rockstars tumblr we're
covering all the miss marvel stuff right
now jessica's doing some great maymays
on there we're having an awesome time
it's been a lot of fun
that's all i got to say john you know
what that's all i got to say can i say
one thing yeah i say one thing one thing
you guys we're being very cautious and
trying and trying to abide by being live
standard when i say cautious i mean
we're not trying to talk over each other
we're trying to correct ourselves so
whitney said to me messages on her
whiteboard
oh my god okay all right all right we
gotta
i love the chat i hate the chat you guys
we broke five hundred dollars oh my gosh
we didn't think we were gonna we didn't
think we were gonna get this far we need
to drink i need to get a new a beverage
um
if you guys give us another 100 i'll put
g fuel in my
that's just like doing digital cocaine
tommy's not here someone has to do
cocaine
that is also very true it's in our
budget uninterested
by the way team ad says best break room
ever sweet of you happy pride
hope you're watching i'm here i hope
you're here
they're like i didn't think she was
gonna make them snort what a annie's
macaroni and cheese what i wrote to
jessica was what what do you think the
chances are that i'm not allowed back
after she's coming back don't worry and
then i draw a picture of brandon
brandon are you okay i look great
okay all right i i don't know who's
supposed to do this segment but it's you
want me to do it
thunder on this channel of course it's
the next big mcu movie coming out and we
want to talk more about it we got a
couple of clips we teased this earlier
not clips excuse me um clips from
interviews that were written out um
from chris hemsworth who was talking
about gore the god butcher a little bit
and we got another plot synopsis for
this movie that gave us
some little hints little bits and bobs
um
so
what's really i'll just read the plot
synopsis if you don't mind so the the
plot synopsis says with the help of thor
valkyrie and the guardians of the galaxy
the mighty thor was faced by the
powerful gore the god butcher um and so
that's a really interesting sentence
right um with the help of the guardians
of the galaxy the mighty thor was faced
by the powerful gor the god butcher i
sort of thought in my little brain
that uh the guardians and thor would
sort of team up at the beginning of the
movie and then the guardians would jet
off into the sun jesus christ
this kind of reminds me when batman
bought the predator a little bit
i was gonna say this is like this looks
just like batman got a joker's hair
i am the shadow i'm gonna have to have a
conversation with philip at the end of
this week
absolutely not john absolutely not we we
kind of thought that the guardians would
be sort of a blip in this movie right
their first act right they were gonna be
on century four and then they would be
like this was too much thor you got us
into some trouble we're going to go star
in our own movie and our own christmas
special right but this sentence sort of
leads us to believe that mighty thor
jane foster is going to be facing off
against gore the god butcher with the
help of the guardians right um that was
a really interesting little tidbit i
want to hear from you guys like does
that re-contextualize sort of the plot
of this movie in your mind peter quill
peter quill's status among the gods in
the mcu i didn't want him to stay that
long in the first place and i still want
to stay that way i know that the comics
were a little bit different but i'm like
i can't look at you seriously
[Music]
get some ice cubes so
what i was saying was i don't want the
guardians to have a longer haul in this
movie than we expected and i think
that's a better idea anyways i have
three movies i have another movie coming
out let them let them keep it i also
think this is a toy description the the
person tasked to write this wasn't the
person who wrote the movie yes it's
someone working who's got that toy
company
who's giving a plot synonym
let's legitimize this for one second
because i i can hear that from the
comments too right
the people who write these toy
descriptions it has to be approved by
marvel you have to think i guess right
and you know they wouldn't just make
this up you know
but they know the guardians are in the
movie and they're like oh they're all
going to fight together they don't show
the movie to the toy people yeah no of
course but i think someone from marvel
is giving synopsis this is why i'm
ignoring ignoring no that was not the
word i'm going to say this is what i
think is wrong and what you said is that
the toy that's the problem though with
marvel and the toys is just that the
toys will immediately shovel it out and
the marvel's like you weren't supposed
to release that yet or you're not
supposed to release that at all so i
think that's a it's a more of a just
like uh we're leaning
that the guardians are gonna appear in
like the second half of this movie we'll
see guardians no but i do think like
maybe they do interfe we're going to get
gore the god butcher sometime in the
first act of this movie it's possible
that there will be some kind of conflict
with the guardians and gore
and they might have to say like
hey
you know i'm a demigod right wouldn't
you consider peter quality
does he show up just because he's called
star lord and he's like oh no
oh no not that guy there was that when
ego died you know uh
lost his god half right he loses all
that power that he just got he like
loses it uh so i do think like uh gore
might show up and do like a sniff test
like you're not a goddess
this is just a guy who loves kevin bacon
movies believable
and i would consider that to be a godly
child oh my god i like the idea that the
guardians bring thor to earth and
they're all hanging out on new asgard
and gore shows up the guardians are like
we'll help we'll help they try and help
and they're like we're out of here this
is not our problem
have we talked about what is
what would you classify gamora knowing
what thanos is
because what he's looking at
with the dvds
so he wouldn't see her and immediately
be like i gotta know everybody he's
probably like happy with what thanos was
doing in a way you think maybe because i
i think that there could be godly
figures that were affected by the snap
so he was like he was on the right track
though we take kill off innocent people
uh just regular people which that we
know for a fact that pisses gore off so
that's true i don't know speaking of uh
gore's of course pleasure uh in an
interview with disney's d23 magazine as
obtained by the direct thor love and
thunder director and actor taika waititi
and star chris hemsworth discussed the
film's big bad gore the god butcher and
they said gore's backstory involves
being wronged by the gods we sort of
expected that right and a lot of his
motivation is getting revenge for those
wrongdoings we really wanted to explore
this idea of religion belief and what it
means to put your faith in a higher
power and because thor is essentially a
god you know what does that mean for him
to represent these gods and there was a
further quote that said something along
the lines of you know
gore gets his power from the gods as
well
or or has divine power or something like
that and so my question for you guys is
like okay gore's relationships to the
gods what what mcu god that we know
about do you think could have
been
jesus christ our lord and savior not an
mcu but i like that i think he kind of
is now let me get into it do you want me
to take off this mask
when jesus created it when jesus created
the earth six thousand years ago okay
let me make sure let me cut you off real
quick he made sure
everyone knows friday's what he's up to
everyone in the chat said how can
jessica see through that mask and the
thing is the eye holes are actually
perfect i can see perfectly i'm also
terrified that we're 24 dollars away
from me shotgunning this you asked for
it you made promises to make sure he
shot guns if somebody dies one dollar
zoom into camera okay no no all right
refocus refocus refocus refocus all
right uh which mcu god really do you
think or celestial or what whatever you
could consider a god right maybe wronged
gore you know uh eric vos has theorized
in certain videos that it could have
been a celestial sort of being born on
his planet his planet that sort of
destroyed his planet killed his family
and and that could be why he's sort of
triggered but do you think there's an mc
god that we already know about
there hasn't been a ton of mcu gods that
we've met until like moon night that
introduced almost doubled the amount of
gods and if it's like contour i'd be
upset i'd be like no
no okay and marvel's comment you know in
the comics each planet kind of has its
own gods and you know they kind of exist
all over the place i if you want to do
one that exists that we know of i would
love for it to be dormammu right oh that
makes more sense oh do you have to do
you have to can you zoom in yeah
oh okay
so what if nowhere is the one and then
we did it and he's just like
that could say or we could enter the
introduction to
go
poor johnny you did this you people did
this to my baby boy john
he's got a lot of work to do we need to
run those walls
oh my gosh oh my gosh
let me let me test let me jump again
what a pro what a pro oh sorry i blocked
it no really are you okay
you really did that we'll keep that
we'll keep going and you we're gonna
monitor john i'm doing great dude do you
have oh you have your apple watch on
keep your heart rate input yes thank you
uh do the breathing exercises hottie
productions said chug it go jessica she
bat hulk
oh let me pull it out
shotgun time sorry and then laughed out
loud i don't think it's very funny uh
josh ghetto plot twist the guardians are
all killed by gore whoa
and the upcoming movies are set
beforehand in the timeline and set up
their tragic deaths i mean going into
the third movie knowing that they're all
already dead would be it's kind of cool
so sadly i'd be into it i'd be kind of
cool well i don't
want a holiday special knowing that
they're all dead they don't even make it
to chris jesus shows up on the holiday
special please don't eat the confetti
okay no i i wanted to finish what i was
going to do
i just want to keep this on i am the
task master of this show oh you did a
bad job
[Applause]
so what i wanted to say was i would like
to be this movie to be the introduction
to the acts of the gods that did do it
you know to the gold god and
um
the black one the gold got it a black
one what are you talking about yeah
those are there no the ones that that
that um the one that had the the um
symbiote on him
oh okay
no you want to see no yes who made the
necklace but when you said gold you have
to just say another color so that's why
i want to see um austin power's gold
member in this movie oh that would be
that would be a fun little thing uh
jordan gonzalez sending in a super chat
john is gonna need a to butt chug alpha
here's what people don't know in the
chat
i drank one of these earlier today
already
i i i need to call it
that was the one that he drank through
his butt
here's a question i have as well right
we we know that sort of gore has this
necro sword we don't know where he got
it necessarily in the mcu um
but we do know that this description
says he has divine powers right that is
he's killing gods do you think he has
killed the god who gave him these divine
100 percent that's how he got the power
he got the power and then the guy then
he killed the god or he killed the guy
and got the power i think i want to
stick so hard to the comics of him
wandering this mask keeps falling on my
face so i gotta keep i'm gonna just hold
like this so i think that he like he's
traveling the desert wandering starving
finds the two gods fighting the other
the golden's killed and then the other
god he's like i'm not gonna help you let
me absorb your powers the symbiote and i
want that to i want that to be the
origin and i want that to be what we see
so bad do you think sony's gonna let
marvel have the symbiotes in this
because they kind of own the symbiotes
they got it's a good faith it's a good
faith i want to say yes but i also don't
want marvel to create something made up
right yes if they do that then there's
no way that venom or carnage or whatever
what have you could come here right so
it's like don't make something up you
might as well just bite the bullet and
yeah just do you know i know a little
bit was left behind yeah we have the
symbiote now in the mcu yeah we got one
what that one a little bit and there's
no way home
someone call pepper potts because
there's goops
take this jet egg and shove it we've
talked about gwyneth paltrow and group
two days in a row now uh we just got a
good super chat you want to right now
yeah sure caleb reaction sent a
lovely super chat that says god does
exist in the mcu yes he does of course
captain america would be the one who had
a line when going after thor for the
first time he says literally there's
only one god ma'am and he doesn't dress
like that i don't remember that line but
it's from the first avengers when they
talk about loki being a god and he's
like there's only one guy well i mean
that line was written by a problematic
person so we can write that guy that guy
was such a virgin for so long no i will
not believe this that he's a virgin
steve rogers had sex
during the time he was on the p.o.w tour
no
there's no way no he was a virgin
in the
you will not do my man's skin no red
flag
in the chat tell me right now if you
think yeah
i mean him and black widow probably
hooked up in winter soldier they came
out of the shower you're saying probably
[Applause]
isn't so crazy and insane what brandon's
saying you're telling me you're telling
me you're a nerdy little man you get
boosted up you get sent on a tour with a
bunch of dancing ladies who are throwing
themselves at you and you say no
everybody let me tell you everything
through the same thing every time i went
through the same thing you believe in
your country you stand for america and
what is right i stand for america's ass
and she was getting something let me
tell you when i was when i was a little
nerdly and not and i was insecure and i
was nervous
i got into my body but also what i was
gonna say that isn't this is the fact
that uh
in deadpool
or not
daredevil and daredevil we are already
uh there is god there is a god or at
least there is someone that people are
worshiping everybody has faith in the
mcu right yeah and he goes and talks to
um his uh oh my gosh
his um i point to you because you're a
reason yeah thank you
i was a baptist okay no we don't have
can i do this for yeah okay but no i was
just saying is it not wrong
well i'm just saying i mean i can show
up to the church that doesn't mean that
god's there doesn't mean that captain
america met god himself and he's talking
about god okay maybe then i'm wrong i'm
so afraid of so many the slack messages
that i'm going to get after this so many
people in chat asking for this show to
go another hour it absolutely cannot
well we should have been asking you once
again
we should answer the super chats we
should answer the super chats if you
guys have any questions i think we have
i think we've answered
well
okay someone did ask happy pride who in
the mcu do you think he's gay oh
oh man i mean i'm not trying to out
anybody or like assume thing based on
anything i mean i assume a few of the
eternals probably do whatever they want
they've been around for a few thousand
years yeah yeah there's no way the
attorney yeah yeah right
that's illegal the spectrum is also in
people that are like i don't see labels
and that is right so it's like people
like loki and valkyrie who are already
sort of confirmed to be either gender
fluid a lot of the guardians are doing
whatever they want out there in space
exactly so on earth you know i mean uh
we could have taskmaster right maybe
possibly potentially let's go oh i'm i'm
very i i'm gonna stand for valkyrie no
matter what even though it has been
mentioned it's definitely like in place
and stone because it's tessa thompson
also tessa thompson would probably make
sure i'm sorry just those just those
photos of dick away did you making out
with readers
i was just like this is the peak of
bisexuals
why won't they just like why i am okay
no please please taika
thank you so much for watching this
episode of the break room i don't mean
to end it but we didn't discuss who won
the costume contest who won the costume
i honestly saw john has the he has
access no john you have access to the
chat just scroll but i think i saw more
hearts than i saw in anything i think
both of you should share the trophy
that's right uh
as dual winners oh hello
scarlet [ __ ]
to she [ __ ] yeah oh yeah she [ __ ]
because she went she which she won't
show you here's she [ __ ] because you're
she-hulk but then you're scarlet scarlet
[ __ ] i'm gonna get fired if we don't
wrap this episode up thank you so much
for watching this episode happy friday
everybody thank you for being there have
a great weekend we'll see you all on
monday come back please vote if you
think i'm not alone goodbye everybody
[Music]
street
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it's true
[Music]
you